[Music]
it's too cold to change out here
[Music]
dang i'm late for mom's rally
[Music]
subway card check you got the house key
yeah
i got it
come on we're going to be late
[Music]
hey dude i am so filling your suit with
snow
are you still wearing your suit yeah you
know just in case
it's gonna be fine
see this is my favorite part of living
in harlem
pop-up street fair best food in the city
awesome music
man this would be great for the last
speed i was working on
i should get back into mixing yeah it's
been a while
what do you think about rio morales you
gonna vote for her
it's still hard to think of mom as a
politician she's been a teacher my whole
life
similar skill sets right growling people
educating them
making sure they don't throw things at
each other
[Music]
hi i'm brian horton creative director at
insomniac games
we're excited to show you this first
look at gameplay from marvel spider-man
miles morales
our story picks up one year after the
events of the first game
and we find miles new home harlem is in
danger
trouble brews while miles mom rio
morales leads an election rally
a war between the devious energy
corporation roxanne and the underground
a high-tech criminal army led by the
tinkerer starts to break out
in this gameplay sequence captured on
playstation 5 hardware
the underground attacks roxon sending
the rally into chaos
in a fight that spills onto the
braithwaite bridge where the underground
tries to steal roxanne's experimental
energy source
new form let's take a look
let's not shoot each other all right
we're after the new form ignore
everything else
[Music]
get rid of him then grab as much as you
can carry
[Music]
[Music]
keep him busy
i have to stop this
people are trapped over there i have to
push past these guys
where is he
no
[Music]
everybody get out
thank you man those people
they're trapped
i've got an idea
i need something they can cross
i can stop this
oh sir
right
[Music]
playstation